my career has been a lot of evolution I
mean I started out wanting to be the
world's greatest rock critic and that's
what I want it to be and I didn't become
the world's greatest I came one of the
top I always thought about putting him
on the top five and that was in the 80s
when I think when the last perience when
music criticism really mattered i wrote
i mean the village voice is my home i
wrote some stuff at the times were
rolling stone but i was really a voice
guy I also worked at Billboard magazine
as black music editor from 1980 22 1989
so I was writing and immersed in a
really wonderful time and sort of black
music certainly in American music okay
but Burke we know it was incredible it
was big burp of hip hop was going on
development of hip hop there was Michael
Jackson it was Prince there was a really
incredible kind of pop sound out of LA
which is the kind of quincy jones solo
records thing that was going on it had
it did spawn tons of hit records as well
so does a lot of vibrancy around and
then I also ended up living around the
corner from Spike Lee and I was an
investor and she's going to have it so i
was around the birth and development of
this kind of the current wave of sort of
black film and for like auteur films
which had never really existed before so
that was i was a chronicler of all of
that stuff I wrote a lot of books I
wrote a ton of articles for all kinds of
publications and that was sort of first
phase in my career and a lot of people
that still who I am through the books
and the fact is I'm a talking head on
tons of documentaries but in the 90s I
sort of became him become more active in
being a creator i guess i started doing
novels it did a number of commercial
novels i wrote and worked on a couple of
hollywood movies one call strictly
business with Halle Berry and CB 4s
chris rock and then i actually ended up
working with chris on his HBO series the
Chris Rock Show and started doing short
films of various kinds one of which
actually ended up in the Toronto
festival and 87 so I began this
transition I was still writing
voice on and off to the mid 90s
regularly and still writing nonfiction
and fiction books I did a book on hip
hop I think came out of 96 97 called hip
hop America which has been translated
all over the place so I was still doing
that but I also was doing these other so
I was in a kind of between my past
identity if you will and sort of
whatever I was becoming and now I pray
basically Emma you know producer
filmmaker dude I still have a book i
have actually anthology of writings
about James Brown that i put together
coming out in spring 08 and i have a
memoir coming out and 09 so but in a way
both those pictures almost like
retentions of my past and basically most
of my foot focus now I produce a
producer series 4 b.e.t called american
gangster profiles of infamous black
gangsters and I've directed a movie for
HBO with Queen Latifah core life
supporting them I'm doing a lot more
that's kind of where I'm going is
directing a lot more stuff I'm actually
working and producing a very funny
hopefully very funny documentary was
Chris Rock about hair and actually going
to India next week with him and a bunch
of people to shoot Chris Rock working to
the markets of southern India trying to
sell black here to Indian hand merchants